children of the Polli Nia kindergarten
are lined up and for the VAM dissipation
a German delegation is about to arrive
development eight from Germany helped
modernize the town's kindergarten the
donors are coming to inspect the
progress the town raised more than a
third of the renovation costs itself the
few Pellini residents who have turned
out to see the children's dance
performance are mostly grandmothers over
1 million Moldovans live and work abroad
the majority in Russia 16 of the 100
children here don't have parents at home
and that's not a lot for Moldova the
country is on the brink of signing an
association agreement with the EU some
speculate that once the deal is through
Moscow could punish Moldova by sending
home many of its migrant workers the
move would devastate the economy or haze
hospital is being revamped another
project that shows the challenge for
Moldova as it inches towards the EU
Prime Minister yuri liang who
accompanied the German delegation he
knows how much word lies ahead that's
one reason he had German consultants to
help with the process the new office of
the German Development Agency in Kish
now is still very much taking shape
minister get Munna has big plans for the
country but he also knows that many
Moldovans are still close to Moscow
listen does not own we know that
elections are scheduled after the
association agreement has been signed
the Iran broth anemia hype the
government needs a majority polls are
difficult to gauge so we're counting on
the agreement being maintained
regardless of whether the current
government is reelected or nukes office
calm down the assets Iran feschi
heightened but
Moldova has set its sights on Europe
despite the uncertainty that will take
it there